m
dans le cadre d'un travail sur
l'environnement et la nature les élèves
de ce1 de l'école docteur martin à
saint-andré se sont rendus à l'espace
régler pour profiter d'ateliers tout au
long de la journée
52 élèves ont participé aux diverses
activités proposées
au programme ateliers cannage ateliers
boîte coyah vielles ateliers manuels
avec la bd r mais également découverte
des espèces endémiques avec la présence
du jardin bretagne a comparé sur
l'environnement nature avec les enfants
on appris à talents des cités le jardin
des cas et le jardin milles et une
saveurs de saint-andré et si en fait
l'objectif c'est accepter de faire
découvrir aux emprunts les objets
artisanaux donc notamment avec le bois
de goyavier qui côtoie tous les jours et
que
justement de voir qu'est ce qu'on
pouvait faire avec ce bois colas et de
découvrir également très sage l'occasion
pour les enfants de découvrir également
le passé de ce lieu emblématique
l'espace red lite et auparavant un
collège
mais bien avant il a été un jardin
historique les textes nous rappelle que
le jardin du roy était avant d'être le
jardin de l'état au bas de la rivière
donc on est sur ce site un site un peu
je dirais historique puisque en 1810 un
certain tel faire un anglais à a pu
bénéficier du terrain et aujourd'hui le
terrain qui est devenu plus tard le
collège jules reydellet est aujourd'hui
devenue espace régler pour annabelle isu
la professeure anciennement scolarisés
au collège jean rédelé le nouvel
aménagement du site est une véritable
réussite et un espace enrichissant pour
les élèves
alors je suis très content
l'hôtel était en fête
et c'est vrai que basso jardin déjà ça
fait revivre le bas de la rivière et
c'est vrai que le conseil général ils
ont beaucoup investi laisse ici ça a
permis notamment classe de venir
découvrir le bois que yahvé de venir
découvrir un magnifique jardin et le
travail qui est fait ici est formidable
à chaque fois que je reviens ici hausse
et rénové il ya de nouvelles plantes etc
de plus en plus attractif pour les
enfants l'espace raid les regroupe les
différentes activités mises en place par
le conseil départemental afin que les
scolaires puissent profiter de tous les
ateliers dans la même journée